i Ron Ian's protests the ayatollahs and
the Democrats cannot stand it bernie
takes on Biden and more as the Iowa
caucuses approach and Nancy Pelosi
finally decides to hand impeachment
charges to the Senate I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a VPN
yet but I got to do here
visit expressvpn dot-com / Ben I hope
you had a wonderful weekend if you've
been watching world events you
understand the world is an
extraordinarily chaotic place we have an
election coming up this year that could
have a massive impact on where the
economy goes the economy is strong right
now but there's still a lot of
uncertainty out there as to when the
economy might start to slow it's
probably a pretty good time to diversify
into an asset like gold fox business
actually just published an article on
how the world's richest people are
stockpiling precious metals right now as
part of their strategy to diversify
according to Goldman Sachs gold could
surge past 1,600 bucks an ounce
within the next year so why aren't you
looking into diversification especially
into something that is never going to be
worth zero I'm talking about gold if you
haven't yet taken the first step of
requesting a free information kit on
gold go ahead and do it if you haven't
converted a portion of your eligible IRA
or 401k to an IRA in precious metals
have that conversation ask all your
questions make sure that you feel
comfortable before you invest and then
when you are ready to invest talk to my
friends over at Birch gold you can ask
them your questions - I've been working
with them for years at this point
there's no obligation you have nothing
to lose to take that first step Birch
gold group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews
when A+ rating with Better Business
Bureau text been - 47 47 47 during the
month of January when you open an IRA in
precious metals you get a free signed
copy of my book the right side of
history
again you have to text Ben - 47 47 47
and open an IRA in precious metals to
get a signed copy of my book at the
right side of history don't - unless
you're comfortable but then if you are
comfortable use my friends over at Birch
gold tax Ben - 47 47 47 alrighty so over
the weekend more dividends from
president Trump's deterrence strategy in
Iran and this was a deterrence strategy
there were reports out today that this
has been in the works the killing of
soleimani for up to seven months the
President Trump had given the stands and
green light to the United States
military to kill Soleimani for months
and months and months and months so the
idea that Trump sort of just did this on
a whim and one day he woke up and is
like kena mani do it them into a
thousand pieces that apparently is not
how any of this went down so Trump kills
Soleimani in the immediate aftermath of
an Iranian backed militia
burning at the United States Embassy and
engaging in months of terror attacks
Teli money is killed and then the
Iranians respond by firing off
couple of missiles from Iran into a rock
they hit a coalition airbase it did in
fact according to CNN hit the sleeping
quarters of troops which suggests very
very strongly that Iran had called the
Barack and said get your guys out of
there because what we don't want is to
break another one in Trump's red lines
because if we violate another one of
trumps red lines our rinky-dink Navy
could be at the bottom of the Strait of
Hormuz by this time tomorrow okay but in
the middle of that little exchange
I mean vote him away in exchange because
the United States didn't fire anything
at Iran but in the middle of that
missile firing by Iran it plane took off
from Tehran within two minutes it was
shot down by anti-aircraft missiles that
were based in Iran which is just a
horrific screw-up by the Iranian
government you'd expect no less from a
terror regime and now Iran has finally
admitted that it shot down at the
jetliner by mistake according to The
Associated Press in the face of mounting
evidence Iran on Saturday acknowledged
that it shot down the Ukrainian jetliner
by accident killing all 176 people
aboard the admission by Iran's
Revolutionary Guard undermined the
credibility of information provided by
senior officials who for three days had
adamantly dismissed allegations of a
missile strike as Western propaganda and
you did hear from the media when the
Trump administration was saying things
like well yeah it was pretty obvious the
Iranians shut down play well can we
really trust the Trump administration on
this sort of stuff we can trust instead
the Iranian administration the Iranian
regime which lies repeatedly about its
own terrorism according to the AP it
also raised a host of new questions such
as why Iran did not shut down its
international airport or airspace on
Wednesday when it was bracing for the
u.s. to retaliate for a ballistic
missile attack on two bases housing US
troops in Iraq no one was hurt in that
attack carried out in retaliation for
the killing of Qasem Soleimani and an
American airstrike in Baghdad Iran's
acknowledgement alters the narrative
around its confrontation with the u.s.
in a way that could anger the Iranian
public Iran had promised harsh revenge
after slowly Monty's death but instead
killing him instead of killing American
soldiers its forces down a civilian
plane in which most passengers were
Iranian on Saturday night hundreds
gathered at universities in Tehran to
protest the government's late
acknowledgment of the plane being shot
down they demanded officials involved in
the missile attack be removed from their
positions and tried police did break up
the demonstrations but this was the next
step the Iranian people and their
outrage which has been roiling for a
year now actually for years been going
all the way back to like 2009 their
banner on Ian's who want to overthrow
because the regime is a garbage horrible
radical Islamist regime the backs terror
around the region with dollars that
could be used for the goods of its
citizens closes off its own economy so
it can pursue this radical Islamic
attempt to spread Sharia law across
various boundaries now all of that is
opposed by a huge swath of Ron Ian's
there's no way to know what those
numbers look like because polling is not
really allowed inside around suffice it
to say the Iranian regime has been
teetering on the brink for quite a long
time and mass protests did emerge in the
aftermath of the shooting down of the
plane according to CNN apologies from
Iranian leaders over the downing of an
airliner last week have done little to
quell mass anti-government protests
spreading across the country thousands
of demonstrators hit the streets this
week on contemporanea and authorities
for shooting down a Ukrainian passenger
plane and killing all 176 people on
board the airliner disaster came hours
after Iran fired missiles at Iraqi
military bases housing US troops that
was retaliation for a drone strike at
Baghdad Airport that killed Qasem
Soleimani in Iran demonstrators are
calling for supreme leader Ayatollah Ali
Khamenei to step down and for those
responsible for downing the plane to be
prosecuted Khomeini have shame leave the
country chanted protesters in the
capital Tehran in footage posted on
social media and it is indeed thousands
of people in the streets by the way when
they show up in the streets for this it
ain't like when they show up for
Soleimani where the government is urging
them to be out there in this particular
case they are risking death because we
have seen 1,500 protesters killed in the
last year alone thanks to the Iranian
government cracking down on roiling
anti-regime protests now the media have
covered this I would say they've covered
it far less and with far less vigor and
enthusiasm than they covered the funeral
for Soleimani which they covered in just
dropping terms you saw Chris Mathew say
it said like Elvis Presley
it's unbelievable if you've seen the
love I do not suspect that you'll hear
Chris Matthews tonight talking about the
bravery of the Iranian protesters
protesting this evil regime that would
cut against the narrative that the Trump
administration in killing soleimani had
also unleashed ground forces in Iran in
terms of actual
Iranian population to push against an
evil regime that threatens the region
and indeed threatens with its global
terror network citizens around the world
I don't think that the media are gonna
play this up in quite the same way
the reason I say that is because they
have not played up in the last year any
of the economic protests that have been
rolling across the country and resulted
in the death of 15
protestors 1,500 protein that's a lot of
people killed by the Iranian military
protests have now spread to other cities
including Shiraz esfahan coming on and a
room I a according to Reuters people
were tearing down posters of soleimani
you're ripping posters off the walls of
soleimani President Trump for his parts
we did his support for the demonstrators
saying his administration will continue
to stand by you
likewise Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu voices support for the
protesters and called on European powers
to increase pressure on the Iranian
regime president Trump tweeted out to
the leaders of Iran do not kill your
protesters all capital letters thousands
have already been killed or imprisoned
by you and the world is watching more
importantly the USA kissing I do enjoy
the president Trump is not somebody
who's going to do the the world matters
more than the United States bottom line
is he understands that the United States
is the global hegemon you piss off the
US the u.s. has been leading the way
here he says turn your internet back on
and let reporters roam free stop the
killing of your great Iranian people
this prompted by the way you let
reporters roam free it prompted people
like Maggie Haberman at the New York
Times who generally is in fairly good
reporter but she actually tweeted out
why won't we let reporters roam free in
the United States something to that
effect so not the same thing Maggie like
you're tweeting that out on the Internet
in a free country where the New York
Times is the largest circulation paper
in the United States other than the Wall
Street Journal and USA Today so I don't
think that's quite the same president
Trump also tweeted out National Security
Advisor suggested today that sanctions
and protests have her on quote choked
off will force them to negotiate
actually I couldn't care less if they
negotiate will be totally up to them but
no nuclear weapons and don't kill your
protesters which seems like a fairly
strong stance from the President of the
United States
apparently the UK ambassador in Iran was
also arrested they temporarily arrested
British ambassador Rob macare he was
summons the Iranian Foreign Ministry
macare was then arrested while in the
middle of a crowd of protesters in front
of Taran's Amir at Kabul at university
he was accused of instigating and
directing radical and destructive
eminent demonstrations he was later
released and he said he was not taking
part in any of the demonstrations he
just went to an event advertised as a
vigil for victims of the tragedy a the
fact is that the Iranian regime has been
cracking down on all of this because the
Iranian regime recognizes that it simply
is is not popular with a huge percentage
of its own population in fact there was
video emerging from the
BBC is pretty incredible video there's
video that emerged from the BBC of
Iranian citizens refusing to stomp on
American and Israeli flags so for all
the talk about death to America death to
Israel I mean there was actually earlier
this year I think we reported on the
show their Iranian protests where people
were chanting I believe it was death to
Palestine because they were so angry
that the Iranian government was sending
hundreds of millions of dollars in
terrorist support to Palestinian
terrorists as opposed to helping to
rebuild the economy in other words
there's a huge number of secular Muslim
secularized Muslims or moderate leaning
Muslims in Iran who are not happy with
the regime turning the entire country of
Iran which has a Wang by the way long
pre-islamic history in Persia turning
that that country which has a long
storied history into just a tool of
Islamic theocracy they're not up for it
now you would imagine this would be like
a pretty good time for everybody be on
the same page right mean this is a good
thing that the Iranian population are
calling out their own regime this is an
excellent development that the Iranian
regime has been exposed for what it is
is an excellent development to the
Iranians back down the Democrats cannot
bring themselves to say this they cannot
bring themselves to simply back the
protesters it's unbelievable I mean it
would be unbelievable except for the
fact that Barack Obama couldn't bring
himself to really back the protesters in
2009 leading to the Iranian regime
cracking down on the protesters even as
Obama tried to negotiate some sort of
nuclear deal with the people shooting
the protesters well Nancy Pelosi the
Speaker of the House she was on this
week on Sunday on ABC and she was asked
about the protest and instead of her
just saying you know I'm fully with the
protesters they are standing up to a
blatantly theocratic evil regime instead
of her saying that instead she said well
they could be out the friend a number of
reasons cuz she just can't credit Trump
for anything she can't write if anything
even remotely smacks of any sort of
praise for president Trump she must
immediately shut it down so here's Nancy
Pelosi undercutting the protest I mean
really this is this is Nancy Pelosi
undercutting Iranian protesters who are
taking their lives in their hands to go
out in the street and protest against
the regime that just shot down a
civilian airliner because it's violent
and evil there were protesters in the
streets before against the regime after
the taking out of soleimani there were
protesters in the street joined together
as you know against us that wasn't good
taking down this plant air
terrible tragedy and they should be held
accountable for letting commercial
flights go at a time that was so so
dangerous but there are different
reasons why people are in the street oh
there are different reasons why people
are in the street thank you for
analyzing all the reasons and never at
any point suggesting them maybe the
reason people are in the streets is
because this is an evil regime that's
been spreading terrorism for years so
the problem is again is what I've been
saying for last several weeks Democrats
and members of the media they're cops in
rock in a hard place the narrative of
the Obama administration is that this
regime had moderated in the aftermath of
the Iran agreements that this regime was
now contained as his regime was now
being integrated into the family of
nations so if there are actual
protesters being shot in the streets
because they are protesting an evil
dictatorial regime Nancy Pelosi doesn't
have a narrative anymore and if it turns
out that those protests have been
exacerbated by the fact that president
from stood up to the Iranians and the
Iranian people are beginning to see
light at the end of this tunnel
she can't allow that either because
again Barack Obama helped strengthen
this regime end of story period this is
what he did he did not weaken the regime
in any way he strengthened the regime in
a number of ways including trying to
open its economy and allowing them to
pursue regional terror and ballistic
missile testing with American allowed
dollars into Iran so Nancy Pelosi the
the hashtag on Twitter today was
trending that Nancy Pelosi was was
basically standing up for the Iranians
whose hashtag Nancy Pelosi fake news
president Trump for his part was going
on Twitter and retweeting everything
that he possibly could
he was retreating Iranians who are
complaining about all of this as a
journalist named Mohamed Mohsen fari who
Trump retweeted who said the Iranian
people are being killed in the streets
by the Islamic Republic but Nancy Pelosi
in the USA supports those who kill the
Iranian people why and then he retweeted
a man named farad Khalifa was apparently
also a journalist I guess in London he
says while the Iranian people are being
killed by the mullahs in the protest
you're lying to the American people the
real people of Iran don't want the
Democrats back terrorists shame on you
for playing with the blood of Iranian
people President Trump was retreating
all of this and you know people in the
media of course never have said about
the most egregious thing that he
retweeted was a picture of Nancy Pelosi
wearing effectively a burka and Chuck
Schumer wearing some form
of Islamic headgear with the Iranian
flag in the background so people are all
over Trump for all of this obviously
because this is what Trump does I mean
President Trump this is where the
comments or on websites of him comes out
right the caller into talk radio for a
president Trump comes out but the bottom
line is that trumps perspective on Iran
is correct in the democrats perspective
on this is wrong it's not just wrong
it's highly damaging to people who are
protesting at the risk of their lives in
all of this now president from tweeted
out the democrats and the figis are
trying to make terrorists soleimani into
a wonderful guy only because I did what
should have been done for 20 years
anything I do whether it's the economy
military or anything else will be
scorned by the radical left do-nothing
Democrats and he says wow the wonderful
Iranian protesters refused to step on or
in any way denigrate our great American
flag it was put on the street in order
for them to trample it and they walked
around it instead big progress yeah I
don't understand why that's a bad thing
and I don't understand why this is
supposed to be supremely controversial
the President Trump is standing up for
the rights of Americans to be safe and
standing up against Iranian terrorism
and why the protesters are being
denigrated by Nancy Pelosi Trump also
tweeted out a few minutes ago the fake
news media and their Democrat partners
are working hard to determine whether or
not the future attack by terrorists only
money was imminent or not and was my
team in agreement the answer to both is
a strong yes but it doesn't really
matter because of his horrible past that
brings us to the next narrative that's
being attempted by the Democrats because
it turns out that their narrative that
some of my nice death was gonna lead to
World War 3 didn't materialize it turns
out that the evidence is very solid that
the Iranian regime is a terror regime
that you're shot down a civilian
airliner and is now being riven by
protests by its own citizens and so they
have to turn to a second narrative we're
gonna get to the Democrats and the
media's second narrative over the
weekend which is a truly egregious
narrative we'll get to that in just one
second first one of the questions in the
aftermath of the Iranian attack was
whether the Iranians would engage in
some sort of cyber terrorism when they
were engage in hacking and there are a
lot of reports all around the media
ecosystem that there were attempted
hacks all throughout the days in the
aftermath of the Soleimani attack and
we've seen this before we've seen the
Chinese government attempting to hack
private citizens we've seen hackers to
plant hackers who attempt to hack major
institutions and grab data well you may
think that people aren't targeting your
data that is untrue you have data that
means people are targeting it it's that
simple
and John Dillinger once said that the
reason
rob banks is because that's where the
money was the reason that hackers are
after your data is because that's where
the data is and this was why you need a
VPN I can say with full confidence
expressvpn is the best VPN on the market
for me this is why I use Express VPN
expressvpn does not log your data lots
of really cheap or free VPNs will make
money by selling your data to add
companies expressvpn instead developed a
technology called trusted server that
makes it impossible for their servers to
log any of your info many other VPNs
actually slow your connection down make
your device more sluggish I've been
using Express VPN for years it is the
fastest VPN I know of the last thing
that really sets expressvpn apart from
the other VPNs is that it's really easy
to use you install it on your computer
one click and you are ready to go you're
putting yourself at risk if you're not
using expressvpn so go ahead and use
Express VPN protect yourself with the
VPN I use and trust use my link
expressvpn comm slash been today get an
extra three months for free on a
one-year package that's expressive VPN
comm slash man again expressvpn comm
slash been to learn more ok so one of
the Democrat narratives over the weekend
was the Nancy Pelosi narrative that
apparently these protests have many
reasons and Trump being doing the right
thing apparently has nothing to do with
it and then the second narrative is that
Trump is of course a crazy person and
that the only reason he attacked
Soleimani is because he's precipitous
now as I say there was a report that
came out over the weekend suggesting
that for months in advance Trump who
greenlit the kill of Soleimani because
Soleimani was in fact the world's
leading sponsor of terrorism around the
world but this narrative of the
Democrats that Trump was doing this
based on bad info bad Intel this was
exacerbated by President Trump because
President Trump very often will get over
his skis in the sorts of information
that he chooses to divulge to the public
now here's the truth what President
Trump tweeted this morning which is that
whether the attack was imminent or not
so Imani needed to go that is 100% true
and as I've been saying on this program
for again weeks at this point since the
Democrats decided to make imminence the
standard the the question as to whether
there was any imminent attack by Osama
bin Laden or Anwar al-awlaki is
basically irrelevant if you're a
terrorist for a living what you do is
pursue terror attacks and so this
bizarre notion that you have to have the
date time and place of a terror attack
on the list in order to kill a terrorist
is just silly towns but this is the
attack that the Democrats are choosing
to pursue which is the own is that Trump
didn't actually have an excuse to kill
us only money despite the fact that Sony
money again was in Iraq
not Iran who's in Iraq the day after a
burning of a US Embassy in Baghdad who's
in the same car as the leader of the pmf
which is in which was an Iranian backed
terrorist group that was responsible for
the burn he was in that car with that
guy by the way that terrorists happen to
have a death sentence in absentia placed
on his head by the Kuwaiti government
for his terror activities in the past
but apparently according to the
Democrats that that's not strong enough
so Laura Ingraham asked Trump about it
and Trump instead of just saying listen
I'm not gonna divulge all the
information that we have at our disposal
because a lot of that has classified
suffice is to say this man was a
lifelong terrorist I am confused as to
why it is that the Democrats what
exactly are they demanding like when his
next terror attack was going to occur
because again we do know that bin Laden
he was basically cut off from everybody
on earth he wasn't even in an electronic
communication with anybody they were
hand delivering handwritten notes to him
because they were afraid that people
would locate him was he a grave threat
like Obama killed him anyway and he did
the right thing
soleimani was a grave active threat that
would be the right answer instead
President Trump says that solely money
was planning attacks on four embassies
and this of course leads to a bit of a
disconnect with he and Trump in his own
intelligence community and defense
department I can reveal that I believe
it would have been for embassies and I
think that probably Baghdad already
started they were really amazed that we
came in with that kind of a force we
came in with very powerful force and
drove him out you know that ended almost
immediately but Baghdad certainly would
have been the lead but I think it would
have been for embassy could have been
military bases could have been a lot of
other things too but it was eminent and
then all of a sudden he was gone okay so
Trump obviously is happy the Tony money
is gone but the fact that he suggests
that the there were imminent attacks on
foreign embassies this does not meet
with the Intel that has been presented
either to the American public or to
Congress apparently so Secretary of
Defense Mark Esper appeared on Face the
Nation he was asked specifically about
this notion that there were four pending
embassy attacks now here's a very
obvious possibility you know we're not
allowed to talk about obvious
possibilities when it comes to Trump's
interpretation we were supposed to
instead take him supremely literally
that there were imminent attacks on four
US embassies in all likelihood what
happened is that the Department of
Defense in the State Department went to
Trump and they said the Iranians are
fond of attacking embassies
attack US Embassy in Baghdad we need to
up security particularly at these four
embassies and Trump took that as there
were imminent attacks on those four
embassies made that that's the likeliest
explanation for the mix-up but the way
the media play it is Trump is
exaggerating it's just like WMD in a
rock guys so money wasn't actually a
threat so money actually was out there
pet and kittens and adopting puppies
that guy was all rainbows and flowers
and then Trump made this up wrong from
his gray easy head about solely money
attacking embassies and now for no
reason a respected member of the Iranian
military dad Samar Kasper is like yeah I
didn't see any evidence pending of the
of the of the attacks but I think it's
likely that a run probably planned to
attack US embassies considering they've
done this like a thousand times what the
president said was he believed that it
probably and could have been attacks
against additional embassies I shared
that view I know other members of
national security team share that view
that's why I deployed thousands of
American paratroopers to the Middle East
to reinforce our embassy in Baghdad and
other sites throughout the region
probably and could have been that is
that sounds more like an assessment than
a specific tangible threat with a
decisive piece of intelligence well the
president didn't say there was a tangel
he didn't cite a specific piece of
evidence what he said is he probably he
believed are you saying that if I meant
one I didn't see one with regard to for
embassies what I'm saying is I assure
the president's view that probably my
expectation was they were going to go
after our embassies okay so he was
saying again what I'm saying which is
that there's an expectation like
broad-based expectation Trump didn't say
that the attacks on the embassies were
in the imminent even that quote with
with Laura Ingraham but this led to the
media suggesting that Trump was
embellishing don't you see so that means
that I I guess Soleimani shouldn't be
killed
I guess now listen I think that you can
ask whether Trump embellishes things the
man embellishes things end of story he
does right when it came to the evidence
for example that al-baghdadi was in a
cave and he was crying and whimpering in
all of this stuff a members of the
Defense Department yeah we didn't see a
lot of evidence for that but that's what
Trump does okay just it take it take
everything he says with a grain of salt
but instead the media in order to try
and debunk the idea that solely money
should have been killed they're like
well I guess it wasn't imminent because
Trump says that it was the Embassy's but
we see no evidence of the embassies and
that means you shouldn't been killed
okay two things can be true ones one
maybe there were no imminent attacks on
the embassies or maybe there were
imminent attack on the embassies that we
just don't know about we don't know the
answer to that but so many money should
have been killed anyway because again a
terrorist does what what he does like
for a living he is a terrorist for a
living and now for a dying here was Jake
Tapper though going after espera
suggesting the president was
embellishing again I think that's a
relevant question to ask for Tapper I
just don't know what the relevance is to
whether selamanya should have been
killed when President Trump lies or
embellishes on a topic this sensitive
and administration officials in Parratt
his claims to avoid drawing his ire the
situation becomes extremely dangerous
for our troops and the American people
his president Trump embellishing I don't
believe so look the bottom line is we
had exquisite intelligence that can only
be shared with the gang of eight so I
understand the frustration of many
members of Congress but was shared with
that gang of eight I spoke to one of the
briefers when the briefers told me was
that most nearly all the members of that
gang of eight believed that the
intelligence was persuasive as well and
that it should not be shared with the
broader membership because the concerns
that it could be released reveal our
sources and methods well he says he's
not embellishing it's just that I can't
you know lock down which four embassies
we're gonna happen or any of that but
and this contributes to a different
narrative for the Democrats and that
narrative as we will see is that Trump
shouldn't have killed Soleimani because
it was based on uncertain intelligence
this is just like the Iraq war yeah
except for the fact that it's not like
the Iraq war because again if the case
in the Iraq war had been saddam hussein
they this has been the only case saddam
hussein is a human rights violator who
murders his own citizens on a regular
basis and is aggressive on foreign
borders wouldn't take a lot of proof to
prove that i mean the man literally did
that pretty much every day okay same
thing is true of soleimani okay there's
nothing new that had to be proved with
regard to who's Soleimani was the man
pursued terror every single day was his
job with the Iranian government but
according to Democrats this completely
undercuts the case that President Trump
has for killing Soleimani in the first
place so that they will do anything they
can to turn again a win into a loss on
foreign policy we'll get to more of this
in just one second president Trump's
favorite pencil-neck Adam Schiff sounds
off I'll guess that in just one second
first have you ever been in a situation
where something in your car breaks down
and then you have to go to an auto parts
store but really you go to auto part
they don't have the right part so go to
a second auto parts store and now you're
driving around in somebody else's car
because your car is at home
and then go to a third auto parts store
and all these parts are overpriced and
and you can't find the exact right part
you know it's a great tool interwebs you
know who knows that the interwebs is
great too all the folks over at Rock
Auto calm it's a family business serving
Auto Parts customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet whether it's for a classic or
daily driver you can get everything you
need and a few easy clicks delivered
directly to your door the rockauto.com
catalog is super easy to navigate you
can quickly see all the parts available
for your vehicle and you can filter by
brands specifications and prices I don't
happen to be a car guy and rockauto.com
looks great for me if you are a car
person I can't imagine how good it'll be
for you because they've got pretty much
everything you could possibly need
best of all prices at Rock auto comm are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car's
gonna need Rock Auto comm go-to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
again go check them out Rock Auto calm
and right shapiro and their how did you
hear about us box that helps the show
and it helps them and helps you because
obviously you're now checking out
rockauto.com getting the best parts at
the best of prices okay so the democrats
jump on the president Trump is
embellishing bandwagon to try and
suggest that President Trump did
something wrong in killing Soleimani
despite the fact that he backed the
Iranians off their overt aggression
despite the fact that the Iranians are
not protesting in the streets the
Iranian regime apparently that's very
bad here's Adam chef Penn's and Nick
Adams chef talking about Trump fudging
the intelligence trying to make this an
intelligence mistake as opposed to a
giant foreign policy when they didn't
have specificity and so when you hear
the president out there on Fox
he is fudging the intelligence and when
you hear the secretary say well that
wasn't what the intelligence said but
that's my personal belief he is fudging
when secretary Pompey was on your show
last week and made the claim that the
intelligence analysis was that taking
sulla Bonnie out would improve our
security and not and leaving him in
would make us less safe that is also
fudging that's not an intelligence
conclusion so again it's all fudging and
why do we do this Trump's point this
morning on Twitter is basically correct
which is yeah
we do is for embassies but guess what
this is what soleimani did and the
struggles of Democrats Nancy Pelosi
suggesting that the protests have for
various reason and I'm shift going off
on the intelligence how about at some
point somebody just says soleimani
deserve to die Trump did the right thing
in killing him this is a good act of
deterrence and we're gonna have to take
precautions against future Iranian
aggression but that's been true for
decades end of story
and we stand with the Iranian people and
we stand with the president standing
against the Iranian people would that be
so hard
honestly like is it that hard apparently
the answer is yes it is indeed that hard
ok now we move on to the 2020 Democratic
presidential race so there's a big
debate coming up this week and that
debate really is featuring a three-way
face-off now Elizabeth Warren is barely
making it into the conversation these
days so really it's about Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders but Sanders is clocking
Warren as well I'll tell you who is not
in the conversation anymore and that of
course is Cory Mac a Booker Cory Mac
Book are this morning it dropped out of
the presidential race in the saddest
story since Toy Story 4 when you finally
parted ways with mr. Potato Head the
real mr. Potato Head candidate Potato
Head is now gone he's replaced his angry
eyes so angry Cory Booker so angry very
deliberate blinking he's replaced his
hand grads with his sad eyes and then he
came out on Monday and sent an email to
his supporters now he's been sending
emails to his supporters for the last
several weeks since Connell Harris
dropped out being like I'm black do you
see me comes out only black guy right
here look right here me black everybody
else their whites up for an from gang he
doesn't care everybody else is white and
let me just tell you you need a black
person on that stage or you're all a
bunch of racists angry eyes I'm so angry
I'm so disappointed with the Democratic
Party we started off with the most
diverse set of candidates in American
history and now it's down to a bunch of
old white people but if I gained if I
gained ground then this will be my time
yeah it wasn't his time it turns out he
was a garbage candidate just like calm
Oh Harris's garbage candidate and now he
is put on his sad eyes
he opened his back took out the sad eyes
rosario dawson pop those in for him and
he said our campaign has reached the
point where we need more money to scale
up and continue building a campaign that
can win money we don't have and money
that is harder to raise because i won't
be on the next debate stage and because
the urgent business of impeachment will
rightly be keeping me in wash
so Booker is using the impeachment as an
excuse for ending his campaign in his
letter to support his book of Rights I
believe to my core that the answer to
the common pain Americans are feeling
right now the answer to Donald Trump's
hatred and division is to reignite our
spirit of common purpose to take on our
biggest challenges and build a more just
and fair country for everyone I've
always believed that I still believe
that I'm proud I never compromised my
faith in these principles during this
campaign to score political points or
tear down others actually very early on
in the campaign he sort of implied the
Joe Biden was a racist he was incredibly
divisive throughout the campaign but
pretended that he was a unifier
throughout the campaign he couldn't
decide whether he was campaigning on
righteous indignation or whether he was
campaigning on hope he changed Barack
Obama kind of stuff and so he was just a
giant fail he intends to run for
re-election to the Senate you'll
probably win because he's in New Jersey
and whatever but this means you know
hashtag oscarssowhite hashtag Democrats
so white and I'm really looking forward
to the latest rounds of recrimination
I always also look forward to the
retrospective pieces in the New York
Times op-ed page about why we all should
take Cory Booker more seriously
basically every time a Democrat of color
drops out we get a round of think pieces
about why that Cannes and it was
actually awesome even though they had no
support he didn't get that forbade Oh
cuz vidoes a white dude but you did get
that for Kamala Harris tons of thing
piece about we're all gonna miss common
was she was so important nope and then
you got it with hooli and Castro Castro
dropped out everybody's like oh man that
hooli in Castro what a guy what a
wonderful wonderful dude it is funny how
the treatment of candidates of color in
the Democratic Party is they are ignored
while they are alive and then at their
funeral everybody gets up in eulogizes
like Marc Anthony over Julius Caesar's
body oh this Julian Castro what a great
candidate he was I come not to praise
Julio Castro but to bury him right
they're gonna do the same thing with
cory booker we're gonna see all these
people now come out of the woodwork cory
booker isn't it sad that he's gone it
just shows the endemic racism american
society
it's like barack obama never existed in
the democratic party they do the same
thing at the oscars by the way the oscar
nominations came out today and already
you're getting me there aren't enough
people of color in the Oscar nominations
where is Lupita Nyong'o didn't she
wooden Oscar like two years ago four or
five years ago for 12 years a slave it
is
like every year you have to they have to
do this like every every single year
also didn't didn't let's face cynthia
arrow
areevo didn't she just get an Oscar
nomination for Harriet so I'm confused
and then in case the Democrats are the
same way Barack Obama never existed and
so every election cycle they're supposed
to prove they're not racist by
nominating a black person or nominating
a Hispanic person and then if they don't
then it's cuz they're racist and then we
lament all those candidates who couldn't
pick up any support cuz they were
garbage candidates okay so what does
this leave us with it leaves us with a
bunch of old white people yes it's the
old white people primary inside the
Democratic Party so in just one second
we will get to the old white people
primary we're the oldest not the whitest
but the oldest person on the democratic
debate stage is gaining momentum in the
vetting odds he's now drawing even with
Joe Biden we'll get to but madam
extenders in just one second first if
you're not already a subscriber you are
indeed missing out head on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribe Priscilla's 10
bucks a month you get our articles ad
free access to all of our live
broadcasts our full show library select
bonus content our exclusive daily wire
app which is indeed a phenomenal feature
if you haven't checked it out yet if you
choose the new All Access plan you get
all of that plus the legendary leftist
ears tumblr and our brand-new ask me
anything style discussion feature it
allows you to engage our hosts writers
and special guests on a weekly basis so
stop depriving yourself come join the
fun it actually is fun no like really
come to it check us out at daily we're
calm go subscribe we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so if you look at the betting
odds today Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders
are basically even in the betting odds
Joe Biden is up by less than a point now
those betting odds don't really mean a
lot considering that back in November
Elizabeth Warren was it like 50% in the
betting odds to be the nominee it just
shows that Sanders does have momentum
going into Iowa and that is particularly
true because Donald Trump did a foreign
policy thing that is good and it was
interventionist and Democrats aren't
allowed to say that it was good and they
aren't allowed to say that the
intervention was useful so instead
they're going to swing toward the
isolationism and that Bernie Sanders had
been promoting idiotic Lee his entire
career because he's always been wrong
about everything right now in the
polling data the latest poll has Bernie
Sanders up in Iowa Budaj edge has been
fading pretty strongly in both Iowa and
New Hampshire according to the latest
Des Moines Register CNN poll this just
came out on January 8th Bernie Sanders
is up at 20 percent followed by
Elizabeth Warren Budaj and Biden all
between 15 and 17 percent the margin of
error in that poll is three point seven
percent so that means that Sanders is
indeed leading it would be sort of
surprising if Sanders does not win Iowa
given the fact that it is a caucus state
which means that enthusiasm really
counts remember in the caucus states
it's not that everybody goes in
Casabella it's that you actually gather
at a caucus place and then there's shows
of hands and all of this social pressure
matters a lot turning out the vote
matters a lot that does benefit Sanders
and then they move on to New Hampshire a
state that Sanders won 49 percent of the
vote just the last election cycle
according to the latest Monmouth poll
that came out on January 7th Budaj edge
is still leading there although it is
basically a group of three right at the
top Bhutto judge xx Biden 19 Sanders 18
if Sanders were to win Iowa assuredly
you would see a boost in New Hampshire
as well CBS YouGov poll that came out on
January 3rd actually has Sanders in the
lead at 27% over Biden at 25% the real
question is whether you're gonna see
some movement for Sanders in Nevada and
if he can win a big victory in either of
these two states what you would need for
Bernie Sanders to take the nomination is
for Bernie Sanders to win big over Joe
Biden in either Iowa or New Hampshire
and then to run the table and take
Nevada as well the Nevada polling again
has been incredibly sporadic there's
only one poll in Nevada in the last two
months and that is a poll that just came
out January 8th from Fox News
it shows Biden up by only six points
over Bernie Sanders that six point lead
is not a large lead when
consider the fact that Joe Biden could
lose the first couple of states and then
the media would turn to Bernie Sanders
might be the guy Bernie for his part is
getting more and more aggressive which
is of course the smart play he's been
sort of withholding his fire until now
he is going after Joe Biden and going
after Joe Biden incredibly hard in fact
he expect in the debates this week for
Joe Biden to be attacks on his foreign
policy record early and often and the
question is going to be whether
Democrats really believe in this sort of
full-on isolationist kookiness of Bernie
Sanders the pro-communist isolationism
of Bernie Sanders who has never met a
communist journey who wasn't willing to
bow before nor as he met a democratic
ally who's willing to stand up for why
are they gonna prefer that are they
gonna prefer these sort of finger in the
wind foreign policy of Joe Biden because
here's the problem that job Biden he is
sort of a muddle through guy muddling
through is in fact America's actual
foreign policy for all they talk about
America's principled foreign policy
since the end of the Cold War muddling
through has sort of been the rule rather
than the exception and the leader in
muddling through his bin Joe Biden who
has taken every stance on every possible
issue for example this week Joe Biden
and John Kerry his surrogate the worst
Secretary of State in American history
they were going around saying that Joe
Biden didn't actually vote for the war
in Iraq he voted to authorize Bush to go
through the process with regard to Iraq
at the United Nations but that is
nonsense Bernie Sanders released a video
from 2003 in which Joe Biden was
praising George W Bush with regards to
the Iraq war the cost of not acting
against Saddam I think would have been
much greater and so is the cost and so
will be the cost of not finishing this
job the president United States is a
ball leader and he is popular the stakes
are high and the need for leadership is
great
I wish he'd used some of this stored up
popularity to make what I admit is not a
very popular case but I and many others
will support him okay so that was Joe
Biden back in 2003 strongly standing by
George W Bush and the Iraq war now of
course he runs screaming from the Iraq
war because it has become sort of the
the popular wisdom the conventional
wisdom that the Iraq war is the biggest
mistake in American foreign policy
history and all this sort of nonsense
Bernie Sanders by contrast the Democrats
have to choose between Joe Biden who
takes every position on every issue but
at least
stands at root that America can't run
away from the world or Bernie Sanders
who has the ability and this is one of
the things that's nice about
isolationism isolationism is always
popular until precisely the moment that
it isn't this is true throughout
American history isolationism was
popular in the run-up to World War one
until precisely the moment the Lusitania
got sunk at which point the American
public was like no screw this we're
gonna bang on the Hun and then we got to
world war ii and isolationism was
extremely popular in the United States
all the way up to really the German
invasion of France and even beyond right
took a year beyond the German invasion
of France for the for the United States
get involved in the war and that was
only after a rover to attack at Pearl
Harbor isolationism is always popular
until it isn't
so Bernie Sanders always got especially
in the last several decades when the
United States has never been on the
verge of being militarily overpowered at
least with World War one in World War
two you could say that the United States
had actual rivals for global hegemony
that has not been true in the past
several decades and certainly not since
the fall of the Soviet Union and so
Bernie Sanders his foreign policy which
is basically what if we just sit here
what if we just sit here and let bad
guys do whatever they want to all over
the world how's that gonna hook it's not
gonna hook us what if we just support
communists all over whatever who cares
that that that is a a fairly popular
position given the fact that America's
power is not truly threatened on an
existential level by any of these other
countries maybe with the exception of
China maybe and even that is more of a
long-term threat rather than a
short-term military threat so so Bernie
Sanders has sort of an inherent
advantage but Democrats are also gonna
have to face up to the fact that Bernie
Sanders is a guy who thinks that the
squad has great foreign policy ideas
Bernie Sanders is on the trail this
weekend and he is stumping for the squad
thanking them for what they do every day
this would be a Oh see who's making
common cause with Jeremy Corbyn the open
anti-semite in Great Britain
this is Ilhan omar who signs letters to
judges asking for mercy on people
recruited to Isis and suggests that we
should sanction Israel but not Iran and
then suggest that we should basically
back off of Maduro in Venezuela here's
Bernie Sanders thanking all of those
people so what you have a choice between
is an isolationist old commie and and
Joe Biden who has the principles of a
jellyfish I wanted to thank Rasheeda to
leap for doing that exactly when she and
other members of the so called
our doing is every day because I know
these guys when they are out they are
fighting what Rasheeda is doing every
day is standing up for the working
families of this country and day after
day having the courage to take on
powerful special interests and she's
really she's really standing against the
tools the tools now again Bernie Sanders
he let's just put this way his group is
rife with anti-semites Bernie Sanders is
not an anti-semite as far as I know
man's Jewish at least by birth but the
but the fact is that Bernie Sanders
surrounds himself with the worst sort of
anti-semites mean he campaigns with
Linda Sarsour no hon Omar an Rasheeda
Talib but put aside the anti-semitism
his actual foreign policy is
extraordinarily radical and so Democrats
made sure all the sloganeering
but Barack Obama did this too right
Barack Obama was into the isolationist
sloganeering then he became president
launched a war in Libya launched a drone
war increased troop presence in Iraq in
Afghanistan had reversed himself an
increased troop presence in Iraq in
order to fight Isis it turns out that
that presidential seat tends to make you
more interventionist because when
threats around the world materialize
well you got to do something about it
but Bernie might not do that and so
Democrats might have to come to grips
with the fact that all of their
sloganeering is generally stupid and
that a man who puts that into practice
is actually dangerous there's an article
in The Washington Post today by Sean
Sullivan talking about Bernie Sanders
his foreign policy says when Bolivia's
leftist president was pressured to
resign by his country's military after
an audit found signs of a tainted
election two months ago many American
leaders showed little interest in
condemning the ouster some said it was a
potentially positive step for democracy
a sign as president trumpeted that the
will of the people will always prevail
a sharply different response came from
Bernie Sanders who immediately condemned
quote what appears to be a coup the
ousted leader Evo Morales would
challenge term limits remain in power
later thanks the senator from Vermont
and Democratic presidential candidate
referring to him affectionately as
brother most of Sanders his rivals paid
little attention to the incident in a
faraway place but for Sanders the
episode offers a glimpse into an
unorthodox foreign policy worldview
basically as the same foreign policy
world viewed as Noam Chomsky has a
radical radical leftist who believes
that America's role in the world is
based in racism imperialism colonialism
it's like he read VI Lenin's imperialism
back in college and you never got over
it a garbage book by the way with the
Iran crisis thrush
Foreign Affairs to the forefront of the
campaign just as Sanders rises in early
state polls Democrats who previously
waved off the Senators views his fringe
now must contemplate the possibility of
a Democratic Socialist becoming
commander-in-chief of the United States
Trump is already up ended the world
order with an America first approach
that tests Western alliances Sanders
would deliver another jolt echoing
someone from criticisms of military
action and free train but realigning the
country's priorities even more strongly
well what that actually means is that he
would presumably try to make alliances
with actual terror groups right he
suggested that the United States
withdraw military aid from Israel and
give it to an actual terrorist group in
the Gaza Strip Hamas beyond his
objections Morales is removal Sanders
has point cently declined to label
Venezuelan president Nicolas Maduro a
dictator because he is a commie
he called Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu a racist for the
great sin of noting that the Arab
parties in Israel stand for the
destruction of the State of Israel he
has campaigned with Rashidah to leave in
Ohio Maher both of whom favor sanctions
against the State of Israel
he said that China has done more to
address extreme poverty than any country
in the history of civilization
neglecting the forced abortion of some
350 million children minimum and the
forced sterilization of presumably tens
of millions of women and also neglecting
the fact the only thing that allowed
China to rise from poverty at all was
their engagement in the free market and
free trade also Sanders opposed the 2000
invasion of Iraq that's gonna be his
bumper sticker against Joe Biden this
week and David Miller former adviser to
six secretaries of State now senior
fellow at Carnegie Endowment for
international peace he says I think
would be a fundamental shift assuming
his principles hold in the transition
from campaigning to governing even some
Democrats note Sanders has put much more
emphasis on domestic policies than
global ones that's right because
domestic socialism is more popular than
international alliances with some of the
worst people on on the face of the
planet
Senator Richard Durbin was a wild
leftist said it hasn't been his strong
suit but Sanders and company are making
the case that Joe Biden is basically on
Trump's side that Biden and Trump are
closer together than Biden and Sanders
which of course is true when it comes to
foreign policy that's a dangerous choice
for Democrats to make but Bernie is
gaining and he is picking up steam also
because running this close to Joe Biden
Elizabeth Warren is still carrying 15 to
20 percent of the vote and so Sanders is
now reorienting himself he's saying okay
well I've got sort of my ceiling here
but if I tear down Elizabeth Warren and
she drops out most of her support will
go to me now what the statistics show is
that a heavy share of those
with Lauren's support we'll actually go
to Biden too but he's not wrong that a
plurality of that support will go to him
this is why Sanders is beginning to try
to push Warren out of the race more and
more quickly by the way if Warren loses
Iowa New Hampshire she's done at that
point she the the race is over for her
she's got to win New Hampshire she's got
to win either Iowa or New Hampshire
because she's got no potential in any of
the future states Sanders is
presidential campaign according to the
Washington Post has suddenly gone on the
attack as he seeks to secure an opening
in the early February caucuses engaging
in a rare dispute with senator Elizabeth
Warren hustling with former VP Joe Biden
drawing an insult from President Trump
which by the way if you're trump and you
want Sanders is your opponent that'd be
your smart move would be to insult
Sanders because then it makes it
elevates Sanders anybody who want to
elevate you insult
although Sanders had mostly resisted
comparing himself with other candidates
his surrogates and aides intensified
their attacks on Biden targeting his
past positions on racial issues and his
vote to sanction the Iraq war a script
first reported by Politico told Sanders
his volunteers to tell voters that they
called on Sanders behalf who had
indicated support for her that Warren's
popularity was limited to the rich and
educated denigrating her electability
Elizabeth Warren for her part was firing
back at Bernie Sanders suggesting that
she was Cuong quote disappointed with
Sanders campaigns script painting
painting her as elitist she used the
opportunity to warn about factionalism
she as I hope Bernie reconsiders and
turns his campaign in a different
direction but Bernie's not gonna make
the same mistake with Elizabeth Warren
he made with with Hillary Clinton which
was who cares about to the emails they
kept saying that over and over and then
it turned out not enough Democrats cared
about her Damn emails to nominate
Sanders he's not gonna make that mistake
with Elizabeth Warren at a certain point
here he's gonna turn and he's gonna
clock Warren and that is what is
happening right now
Sanders his emergence at the center of
the clashes reflected his pivotal
position in the race for the Democratic
nomination a little more than three
months after suffering a heart attack he
has moved to the top of the polls in
Iowa again I got that one wrong I
thought after he had a heart attack the
Democrats would be like okay this old
one is done apparently not apparently he
still has that solid base and all of the
Democrats who kind of supported Warren
and Budaj edge have come back around to
Sanders vs. Biden and that's not as
clear-cut a debate as as people thought
that it would be Trump for his part was
tweeting about Bernie
sort of cryptically he tweeted quote
well crazy Bernie Sanders is surging in
the post looking very good against his
opponents in the do-nothing Party so
what does this all
stay tuned well let that really the stay
tune means that Trump's about to unleash
a barrage of attack ads on Bernie
Sanders Bernie tweeted back at Trump it
demeans willing to lose well a little
bit early for that there Bernie but
suffice it to say that the debates this
week should be a lot more fraught than
the debates in the past Democrats are
running out of time to attack each other
they can't just hug each other until the
end of this campaign and hope to win
Elizabeth Warren is gonna have to go
after Sanders Sanders is gonna have to
go after Elizabeth Warren I think
Sanders best comes away best in that
exchange Warren does not have a point of
differentiation for Sanders she hijacked
his medicare-for-all plan and then ran
away from it she's lied about her own
policies a thousand times she's not as
authentic as Bernie Sanders says
authenticity counts a lot on that stage
Joe Biden can just point to the fact
that Bernie is kind of a kook and when I
said kind of I mean a massive massive
kook products with Budi judge to bang on
Bernie for that same issue but that does
put Bernie at the center of the stage
and Bernie is the one who is who's
seeming to to break loose right now it
is late in the game I mean this is a
Bernie as a wild-card team in the NFL
playoffs you win your last four games
isn't Lee going to the playoffs riding
on a streak and you're the Tennessee
Titans so do not count Bernie out at
this point again as I've said good for
Trump bad for the country good for Trump
in the sense that easier for Trump to
run against Bernie than to run against
Biden very bad for the country in the
sense that the possibility of Bernie
Sanders as president of the United
States is absolutely terrifying
okay time for a quick thing that I like
and then we'll get to a quick thing that
I hate so things that I like
enjoy Behar met with Nancy Pelosi the
other day so it was a great meaning of
brilliant leaders they took a picture
together
try Behar tweeted out Nancy and I
calculating Trump's lies to date I guess
on her phone be Nancy and me Julie she's
what what a genius she is and it's
always it always assures me when Nancy
Pelosi meets with a person who hates
from so much that she applauded Richard
Spencer on her show the other day but I
like it at least they're out front about
the the people of whom they are fond so
Joy Behar and Nancy Pelosi getting
together other things that I like today
so the Democrats are beginning to
realize that Nancy Pelosi's impeachment
effort is a giant fail the Washington
Post Rachel bade explained over the
weekend on this week on ABC
that many Democrats internally are
saying that Nancy Pelosi strategy did
not paint Mitch McConnell into a corner
on impeachment that instead she
basically accomplished nothing here's
the Washington Post Rachel bade she was
clearly putting a positive spin on what
a lot of Democrats have privately said
was a failed strategy I mean she and
Chuck Schumer the minority leader in the
Senate set out to number one try to get
a commitment from McConnell on witnesses
firsthand witnesses to happen testify in
a Senate trial she also said she wanted
to see a resolution about you know how
the whole proceedings would be governed
she got neither of those and that of
course is exactly true Nancy Pelosi is
basically acknowledging her own
irrelevance at this point she's
protesting against the fact that her
strategy was an enormous failure so
aside from being on this week in
denigrating Iranian protesters she was
also on this week and she suggested that
no matter what happens from here Trump
is impeached for life well yes I was
Bill Clinton has that hurt his legacy in
any real way not much not much it turns
out to be impeached but not expelled
from office does not have any real
long-term impact on the way that the
American people view you especially when
it turns out that was done with only
Democratic votes but Nancy please like
we did our part we spoke for history
okay here's Nancy Pelosi adventurers are
moving we had can't we have confidence
in our case that is impeachable and this
president is impeached for life
regardless of any gamesmanship on the
part of Mitch McConnell however that
could still come to bear but we're
confident in the impeachment and we
think that it is enough testimony to
remove them from office however we want
the American people to see the truth and
what why are they afraid of the truth
okay there's gonna how the American
people see this week he's impeached
forever forever he's engaged
yeah sure you really you really have
changed the world Nancy Pelosi pretty
MIT put her on the tougher of the cover
of Time magazine for her brilliant
manipulations okay time for a quick
thing that I hate
so there's an article from Ariana in
jeong-ja over the Washington Post it is
called five years after an abortion most
women say they made the right decision
first off we should just acknowledge
that when people make a decision in life
it is extraordinarily rare that they
look back and they say publicly that was
a mistake there's a rare thing it's a
rare thing for people to feel shame or
guilt about things they have done
especially something as morally
deplorable as killing an unborn child
because in order for you to look back
with regret you have to acknowledge the
enormity of what it is that you just did
in order for you to look back with
regret you have to acknowledge that you
committed about as grave a sin as it's
possible to commit on this earth to go
along with to stumble to to choose to
kill your own child is an extraordinary
extraordinary sin and to acknowledge
that is obviously going to lead to some
significant cognitive dissonance the
feelings of shame and regret the fact
that any women do it is a sign of moral
courage seriously and you see this
throughout the world and I've spoken
about this documentary that came out
this year it was not nominated for Best
Oscar documentary this is the biggest
oversight actually one child nation
which i think is the best documentary in
the last ten years even there it was
amazing the filmmaker at the very end of
the film tries to make the case for
proably sort of pro-abortion case in the
United States because there in China
women were forced into abortions but
here they get to choose abortion that
makes all the difference and no I mean
either that's a life or it's not a life
either you more in the life or you don't
learn the life they're two separate
issues one is the invasion of women's
choice and the other is what the woman
is choosing to do a forced sterilization
for example is a very different evil
from allowing abortion these are two
very definition in any case that that
film which is all about the the evils of
a bore of forced abortion it has an
entire section in in one child nation
it's really unbelievable about how many
Chinese women because they wanted a boy
if they had a girl the girl is
completely born okay this is in the
fetus the girl is completely born would
take the baby to the market drop the
baby off in a wicker basket at the
market and just leave the baby there and
if no one took the baby the baby would
die of heat exposure which I have
exposure to termina to to insects or or
starve to death
and
and what was amazing about the
documentary is that the documentarian
then went back and talked to all these
women and asked did you dislike the
one-child policy was it wrong and women
say no do you feel you didn't anything
wrong
knows what we had to do at the time
that's just what the policy was the
human capacity to go along with evil in
order to justify our own actions is
nearly endless it's why what good people
have to spend time doing everyday is
what we in Hebrew call teshuva
right we have to spend an enormous
amount of time examining our own actions
trying to examine our own actions for
the sins that we may have committed in
Judaism this is a big thing in
Christianity obviously this is quite a
big thing it should be a big thing for
any good person whether you're religious
or not religious but the point being
made here is that the fact that there
are any women at all who have an
abortion and then feel bad about it
later is a sign of the human capacity
for a penance and that's good but the
way the study is done if women don't
regret it that means that women should
have the right to do it which is an
insane standard right I mean obviously
OJ Simpson I don't think regrets killing
Nicole Brown Simpson that doesn't mean
that he had a right to do it The
Washington Post the reports there's been
quite a lot of research about women's
emotions immediately following an
abortion some experience sadness guilt
and anger others feel relief for many
it's a mix of all of these and more but
what about in the long term researchers
from the University of California at San
Francisco delved into this question in
an analysis of 667 women recruited from
30 sites across the country as part of
the turn away study a landmark body of
research about how women abortion
affects women physically socially
emotionally and economically starting
one week after their abortions and then
twice yearly after that the women were
asked about their feelings the author
said they wondered about stigma and how
the women would reflect on their
decisions as time passed what they found
was a surprise over time all emotions
good and bad faded
well that that makes sense I mean as
time goes on people rarely feel the same
way as they do in the heat of the moment
a really interesting finding is how the
intensity of all emotions is so low said
Carina Roca lead author of the study and
a UCSF associate professor of obstetrics
and gynecology and reproductive sciences
a week after their abortions about 51
percent of women expressed mostly
positive emotions 17 percent expressed
in negative emotions and 20 percent said
they had few or none as time went by the
number who felt fewer nun emotions rose
sharply at the five-year mark 84%
reported either primarily positive
emotions or none at all
while 6% had primarily negative feelings
there was no evidence
new negative or positive emotions the
author said immediately after their
abortions 95 percent of those who agreed
to interview said they'd made the right
decision first of all that makes sense
again that is a real subsection agreed
to interviews and what are you gonna
agree to an interview be like yeah I
really have that one up that was my
child my kill bit what do you think
that's a self-selected group in other
words at five years that it percentage
increased to 99 percent Roca was careful
to point out that a woman's feelings of
regret and her judgement that an
abortion was the correct decision for
her under the circumstances are
different things you can feel the
emotion of regret yet feel what you did
was right for you so in other words she
thinks that it's a hundred percent of
women who should not feel any regret
about what they did the study authors
wrote that their findings challenged the
rationale for state mandated and
counseling protocols and other policies
regulating access to abortion premises
on emotional harm claims eg waiting
periods well no actually because those
waiting periods are based on the idea
that women have not in many cases fully
considered the possibility of what it is
they're doing that a lot of the state
mandated regulations with regard to like
seeing 40 ultrasounds are designed to
give the woman more information before
she just goes in there on the vague
promise that that fetus is actually just
a cluster of cells but according to Roca
what the study is showing is that there
is small minority who do regret their
abortions I know I want to reduce the
struggles of those who regret that
abortions but it is misguided to take
away options for everyone based on this
minority well no usually the attempt to
take away abortion has very little to do
with the emotional status of the women
affected has a lot more to do with
trying to grant women more information
so they can make a morally proper
decision with regard to whether or not
to dispose of their own child but again
the study itself is incredibly foolish
in the sense that most people have an
incredible capacity as have said for
overlooking their own sins for not
regretting their own sins and the fact
that anybody regrets what they've done
in the past is a sign that the human
being is capable of change and so does
the job of good-hearted people who care
about the unborn to make the case to
women that even that your your feelings
of regret should not be a barrier to you
or or your your feeling that you don't
want to feel guilty you should not be a
barrier to you changing your mind it's a
sign of you being a better person right
when you repent a sin
that makes you a better person not a
worse person in in sort of Jewish
thought there's a whole school of
thought in the Talmud that suggests that
if you have sinned and you repent the
sin in some ways this makes you greater
than the person who has never sinned at
all because you've now had to go from
the depths to the heights as opposed to
having been in the heights the entire
time there's a whole school of thought
in the Talmud that says that your sins
actually turned to merits when you fully
repent those sins and recognize that
what you did was wrong that's how
difficult it is to do repentance so if
this is true and every score not just
abortion we should all be examining our
actions every day to determine what it
is that we did that was wrong how we can
do better in the future but the this is
why the pro abort movement tends to push
the shout your abortion idea because
once you've shouted your abortion it's
very difficult for you then climb down
from that perspective and suggest wait a
second I never should have shouted that
abortion that abortion was wrong
alrighty we'll be back here a little bit
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow in preparation for the big
democratic debate I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam sai events audio is mixed
by micro Romina hair and makeup is my
Jess well alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 the Iranians take to the
streets to protest their dirtbag
terrorist leaders in exactly the way
conservatives predicted they would in
direct opposition to two weeks of
leftist howling we will examine how
Trump got it so right and why reality
contradicts the left's international
world view then Ernie takes the lead in
Iowa Democratic Party elites are furious
I couldn't be happier then brexit necks
it in the passing of one of the great
conservative thinkers of our age check
it out on the Michael Nolt show